Will drinking coffee give you cancer?
According to the state of California it might.
They might be putting warning labels on coffee
that it contains a cancer causing chemical
what's your reaction to that?
Uh, I mean it's pretty crazy, I mean what's
that trope?
Nowadays every says everything will give you
cancer.
You can't treat adult people like they're,
I don't know, babies.
I appreciate a state government that cares
about it's people,
I love California, I'm very happy that this
is my adopted state,
but that's ridiculous.
California Proposition 65 is an extensive
regulation
continuously changing to meet the demands
of consumer safety.
Thanks to Prop 65 enacted in 1986 businesses
are required to post a warning
about the presence of any substance known
by the state's Environmental Hazard Office
to cause cancer or reproductive toxicity.
The list is updated yearly and it now contains
more than 800 substances
almost everywhere you look in California there's
a Prop 65 warning.
Apartment buildings, restaurants, even Disneyland.
What are some of the places where you've seen
those?
Restaurants.
Yeah restaurants or like different stores
that might be microwave food.
See 'em like at the Echo Park Pool where I
go swimming.
When I see one of those signs it doesn't make
me thing twice about the establishment
because I see them everywhere.
So I recognize that it's kind of a blanket
attempt to protect people
perhaps from themselves.
And a recent ruling from a Los Angeles judge
orders major coffee chains like Starbucks and Pete's
to post explicit warnings that chemicals in
coffee might cause cancer.
We stationed ourselves near a coffee shop
in Los Angeles
and asked people how far they think labeling
should go.
I'm glad they care, I'm still gonna be slamming
cold brew pretty regularly
and that may be what ends me but I'll go very
alert.
Does it give cancer?
I'm about to get some right now.
Acrylamide and appears on California's list
because studies show that lab rats are more
likely to develop cancer
when administered extremely high doses of
the chemical.
A human being would need to drink approximately
35 thousand cups of coffee
or a mere 16 thousand cups of instant coffee
a day for life
to reach those Acrylamide levels.
I'm not gonna drink that much, just a cup.
And the World Health Organization has said
there's inadequate evidence
that coffee drinking increases cancer risk.
If it makes people feel better
and if it makes some representative feel like
they did their job that's good for them,
but I think most of us are going to continue
drinking a lot of coffee.
It's gonna get to where there's going to have
to be signs on the air, air causes cancer.
It's like, any-
It does though.
I know that's what I'm saying!
Some other chemicals on the list include Formaldehyde
and Arsenic
the latter of which occurs naturally in apples.
Should apples be labeled as containing Arsenic?
I mean you're not gonna be able to label an
apple tree,
I mean the tree comes from the ground, comes
from the soil it's probably that.
In the grocery store?
In the grocery store, yeah, like an individual
label I don't know
but on like a bag of apples, sure.
Apples don't actually have to be labelled
because the chemical occurs naturally
rather than as a byproduct of human intervention,
an exception in the law.
Is there any danger in like over warning,
if people do become numb to things that aren't
necessarily serious harms
and they ignore, like, the real warning.
Yeah I guess I could see your point there
because I see warnings all the time I never
really pay attention to them.
It goes in here and out there, I mean so its,
I don't take it serious at all.
Besides the possibility of numbing citizens
to real dangers
over warning brings other costs
such as those to business owners who are regularly
sued for failing to post adequate signage.
One trade association estimates that the typical
non compliance lawsuit settlement
to be 65,000 dollars per item.
What about the costs that it imposes on the
businesses
because they would have to actually test,
in a lab their food, a little deli counter
do you worry about, you know, maybe that effecting
the price
for people who need access to fresh food?
I didn't think about that but I don't know.
You think it's worth it, though?
Yeah I think it's worth it.
And cancer warnings aren't the only labels
that are required in California.
The state also mandates calorie counts in
fast food restaurants.
This idea proved much more popular than the
people we spoke with.
Nutritional labeling makes sense because it's
just telling me about content
it's not making a moral judgement for me.
I absolutely enjoy it because I will instantly
look at the caloric intake
because that's become very educational.
I guess it's good for some people,
I obviously don't count too many calories
but-
But a recent report on nutritional labeling
from the USDA
concludes that the best designed studies show
that calorie labels
do not reduce total calories ordered at restaurants.
We are educated to the point now that we know
that everything is an issue
you know everything can cause something or
do something to us.
I mean there is a problem with like eating
disorders and stuff like that
and I think that that kind of labeling just
makes that worse.
The California Department of Health has proposed
rules to require calorie counts
anywhere that serves food
including deli counters and grocery stores.
Does that worry you at all that that puts
a burden on the smaller businesses
to have to comply with that kind of labeling?
No it's just finding managers and people who
are capable and willing to take part in this.
If I want to go someplace I'm gonna go someplace,
warnings are a good thing but if I want to
go to the haunted mansion I'm going to go
and I'm gonna get coffee while I'm there.
An increasingly popular idea is the mandatory
labeling of genetically modified foods.
Do you know if this has GMOs in it?
You have to scan that new code on the back.
Really?
A ballot proposition requiring GMO labeling
failed by only three percentage points in California
and other states like Connecticut, Vermont
and Maine
have actually passed GMO labeling laws.
Scientists have produced no evidence that
GMO foods cause harm to humans.
I think GMO labeling is helpful.
Again, people can have informed consent, they
can decide what they want to do.
So how much labeling is too much labeling?
The state of California seems right on track
to test that question.
If we're a laboratory state and other states
can look to us and see what worked and what didn't
that's fine by me, it's at least an interesting
place to live.
I don't always love what happens here but
I'm never bored.